Rapunzel once upon a time there was a
girl named Rapunzel Rapunzel lived in a
tall tower in the middle of a forest the
tower had no ladder no stairs and
definitely no elevator there was no way
to get up or down so why did Rapunzel
live in a tower well it all started with
a witch as you know witches can be very
jealous they especially hate people
stealing herbes from their gardens
unfortunately Rapunzel's mother didn't
know this about witches many years ago
when she was pregnant with Rapunzel she
snuck over the fence and stole some
parsley from the witch next door the
witch saw her stealing parsley she was
furious
she gave Rapunzel's mother two choices
option 1 the witch would curse her
unborn baby girl the girl would always
be unlucky she would meet the wrong
people and say the wrong things and wear
the wrong clothes for every occasion she
would never live happily ever after
option 2 on the girl's 10th birthday she
would go to live with the witch she
would be the witch's apprentice the
witch promised that eventually the girl
would live happily ever after
Rapunzel's mother was heartbroken she
chose option 2 and on the evening of
Rapunzel's 10th birthday the witch came
to take her away
she put Rapunzel in the tall tower in
the woods
[Music]
after that every day was the same for
Rapunzel she cleaned her room at the top
of the tower she braided her long long
hair and every day at lunchtime the
witch came to the tower
she stood under the window and shouted
rapunzel rapunzel let down your hair
Rapunzel through her braids out of the
window the witch climbed up Rapunzel's
hair like a rope and crawled in through
the window the witch thought Rapunzel
how to make medicines with herbes and
Rapunzel loved the witch she was
Rapunzel's only friend
one night Rapunzel was reading a book
beside the window when she heard someone
below rapunzel rapunzel let down your
hair that's strange
she thought the witch never comes this
late she threw her braids out of the
window and the person climbed up up up
but when this person reached the top
Rapunzel saw that it wasn't the witch it
was a man
Rapunzel quickly grabbed her book and
smacked the man in the head get out get
out
you're not the witch the strange man
fell to the floor
oh stop hurting me he begged who are you
what do you want why did you climb my
hair demanded Rapunzel I'm Justin my
name is Justin he whimpered I came here
to save you
as you can imagine Rapunzel was not very
impressed
tell me Justin she growled does it look
like I need to be saved
just inside I'm sorry I thought this was
my chance to be a hero what do you mean
asked Rapunzel my chance to be a hero
every man needs to be hero at least once
in his life it's the only way to live
happily ever after
Rapunzel put down her book I don't need
a hero she said kindly go away
be a hero somewhere else it's late I
want to go to bed
Rapunzel threw her braids out the window
well can I come back and talk to you
tomorrow
Justin asked you seemed nice also I
brought a rope for you in case you
change your mind one day fine fine said
Rapunzel goodbye Justin and Justin
climbed out the window and down
Rapunzel's hair the next day Rapunzel
cleaned her room and braided her hair
the witch came at lunchtime she brought
Rapunzel a sandwich and showed her how
to make medicine to cure headaches but
as the witch was leaving she saw
Justin's rope lying on the floor whose
rope is this where did you get it do you
want to escape
Rapunzel tried to explain but the witch
was too upset I love you like a daughter
do you really hate me so much that you
want to leave No
there was a man sent Rapunzel
a man the witch cried fine go to him go
tears poured down the witch's face go
and live happily ever after with this
the witch threw some magic powder at the
floor and Rapunzel immediately fell
asleep when she woke up she was not in
the tower anymore she was lying under a
tree in the forest
her hair was cut Rapunzel cried for ten
minutes and then she stood up and
decided to look for her tower meanwhile
back at the tower
Justin returned as promised rapunzel
rapunzel let down your hair he shouted
from beneath the window and the hair
dropped down in front of his face but as
I'm sure you know it wasn't Rapunzel in
the tower it was the witch when Justin
got to the top of the tower the witch
pulled him in through the window the man
who wants to take my Rapunzel she said I
see well then go and live happily ever
after together the witch blew a handful
of powder into his face and with that
Justin was blind
after walking all night Rapunzel found
her way home but the tower was gone all
that was left was a burnt circle on the
ground Oh cried Rapunzel and she fell to
the ground sobbing but then she heard a
voice coming from behind some trees
hello is someone there can you help me I
can't see I can't see anything it was
Justin when Rapunzel saw Justin's blind
eyes she knew what to do stay right
there
she ordered Rapunzel ran into the forest
to find some herbs she ground the herbs
and made medicine then she put the
medicine on Justin's eyes then she cried
again please don't cry said Justin
softly why are you crying my home has
gone my only friend is gone you are
blind this is a mess everything will be
okay
Justin said then he smiled trust me
I'm a hero for three days they camped in
the forest
Rapunzel made medicine for Justin's eyes
Justin told her about every time he had
tried to be a hero
once he tried to fight a giant but the
giant was very kind he invited Justin
inside for tea
once he tried to kill a dragon but the
dragon had baby dragons in its nest
Justin couldn't do it once he rescued a
cat from a tree but the cat immediately
climbed back up it's really hard to be a
hero he complained when Rapunzel felt
like crying Justin told jokes until she
laughed when she couldn't sleep he
listened to all her worries on the
fourth day when Rapunzel woke up Justin
was already awake he was looking at her
with his bright blue eyes he could see
thank you my beautiful friend he said
you fixed my eyes Justin and Rapunzel
walked to Justin's village
Rapunzel liked it in the village Justin
helped her build a new tower and this
time the tower had stairs
Rapunzel spent her days making medicine
for the sick people in the village did
Justin ever become a hero yes of course
there are many kinds of heroes but the
best and bravest heroes are the ones who
help their friends through hard times
and Justin had helped his friend
Rapunzel in the end Justin and Rapunzel
both lived happily ever after
just as the witch had promised
[Music]